oh it's about to start ready ready
popcorn but nachos she prepare with
bread Lucretia
it's time we made a new movie good idea
Scoob but first we need a trailer oh can
you do the trailer high voice let me
give it a shot in the world destroyed by
evil discover the epic origin story the
greatest team of heroes
of mystery nailed it
[Music]
hi this mangy stray is coming with me
he's not a stray okay then what's his
name his name's you Scooby middle name
doobie last name do would always be
without you laughing lost at sea I love
it darkness forever taking off maybe
don't do that again I'm Fred this is
Velma hi and that's Daphne hey I'm
Shaggy and this is scooby-doo nice to
meet you
retreat
yeah
No
whoa whoa whoa Shaggy and Scooby were
taken do you realize where we are no
look a real man the clean modernist
thing the cool blue color palette
we're in Mikey did you say I can't nope
I said Falconeri just like you maybe
this can lead us to Scooby and Shaggy
trace amounts of moustache oil 12 year
old scotch it's the bad guy my dad
[Music]
you